>> Marv: MISSES BOTH.
AND GAFFORD HAULS DOWN THE
REBOUND.
HE STEPPED OUT.
HE LOST HIS BALANCE TRYING TO
SAVE THAT PASS THAT WAS SLIGHTLY
OFF AND WESTBROOK STEPPED OUT OF
BOUNDS.
>> Grant: LOOKED LIKE HE
MAINTAINED HIS BALANCE SAVING
THE BALL.
AS HE TRIED TO GO UP COURT, HE
STEPPED OUT.
I DON'T KNOW.
LOOKED LIKE A SEAN ELLIOTT -- I
DON'T KNOW IF HIS HEEL WAS DOWN
ON THE OUT OF BOUNDS THERE.
WE WILL HAVE TO SEE ON THE
REVIEW PLAY.
REMINDS ME OF 2000 WHEN SEAN
ELLIOTT HIT THAT THREE-POINTER
AND HEELS WERE CLOSE TO THE
SIDELINE.
CAN'T TELL FROM THAT ANGLE IF HE
ACTUALLY TOUCHED IT.
>> Marv: VERY CLOSE.
>> Grant: MIGHT HAVE TOUCHED IT
FROM THAT ANGLE.
>> Marv: SEAN ELLIOTT, YES.
>> Grant: THAT WAS 2000, RIGHT?
>> Marv: RIGHT.
>> Grant: AGAINST THE PORTLAND
TRAIL BLAZERS?
>> Marv: RIGHT.
WENT OUT TO DINNER THAT NIGHT.
RUSSELL UPSET THAT HE EVEN GOT
THAT CLOSE TO THE LINE.
>> Grant: YEAH, I DON'T KNOW.
IT'S TOUGH TO TELL THERE FROM
THAT ANGLE.
I DON'T KNOW IF IT'S ENOUGH TO
OVERTURN THE CALL.
RUSS FEELS LIKE IT'S ENOUGH.